the first time I saw this bottle it was
I think I was 16 years old it was shown
to me by my sister's boyfriend it was a
pretty good player at the time and no
matter how many times we played I could
never beat him and I've never actually
seen the scene this puzzle anywhere else
since then and that was about 15 years
ago so I don't really know the origin of
this puzzle if any we do feel free to
feel free to leave a comment in the
comment section about it but
nevertheless this is the an amazing
puzzle and I remember it clearly and
every time I someone asks me to show him
a chess puzzle this is the first puzzle
that I show them so this is the puzzle
and I couldn't solve it it was beyond my
level at that time I could I only played
with a couple of my friends and the only
thing I really know about chess was you
know to put the knight on c3 and f3
castle and maybe put a bishop on c4 that
was the depth of my chest knowledge so
this is the position here you can pause
the video and try and solve this cool
puzzle so for those of you who have
paused the video and have tried to solve
this puzzle I'll help you were
successful and for those of you who
still want to see the solution and
weren't able to solve the puzzle this is
a this is the solution so the thing
about this position is that black is
threatening a checkmate here Queen to e1
checkmate and it's not that simple to
stop this checkmate
whatever more white plays the black will
just play Queen do you want a nice
checkmate
so the first move is rook to see a check
and this force is black to capture the
rope there is no other legal move so
here black will capture the rope
rotate c8 and here capturing the room
doesn't really achieve anything that
black is off upon and well even if even
if white good plate is it's still not a
very good solution to the puzzle so the
next move is the one you have to find
there when you when you calculate this
route to c8 its Queen to a7 check and
here at Black has two options you can
either accept the Queen sacrifice so he
can play came to c7 and if came to c7
then simply grabbing another Queen wins
the game easy
so obviously this isn't the move we had
planned another option is to capture the
Queen and this is actually also not good
but it's better for black to go this way
and here white will take the route and
c8 and promote his phone into a knight
and he will pin the king and the Queen
and after the King knows the knight will
capture the Queen and this is the
solution to the puzzles and the position
here is now easily waiting for white so
after I saw this I actually was amazed
at all the great secrets and hidden
possibilities chest head and after this
I started reading books about chest I
started the solving puzzles and then I
actually joined a chess board so yeah
this is the puzzle that made me fall in
love with chests and I hope you enjoy it
as well and see you soon